now it is time to show you some gameplay
of brain dance this is a feature that
you'll experience when you play
cyberpunk 2077 brain dance is
essentially a recording of somebody
else's experience it allows you to
relive their sense of sight smell touch
and even hearing all thanks to a special
device after the gameplay I will be
welcoming back Pavel Sasuke
I will also be joined by Patrick Mills
our senior quest designer and all-round
law master who will be helping to answer
your questions and give you some
explanation on how you'll be interacting
with brain dance when you play cyberpunk
2077 so let's take a look
planned simple do nothing odd don't get
creative you go in snatch the cash get
out and we sell the Biddy to go psycho
freak small studio got it got it and
remember everything on full blast
they'll spot us extra for a wicked
adrenaline I
okay on you go
down everybody on the ground what I see
you kissing the flooring money now swear
I will [ __ ] drop you I swear to God
well yeah yeah now before I blow your
[ __ ]
ah slow deep breaths your cortisol and
adrenaline spiked but the soft activated
your hormone blockers nothing happened
you're alive and well
that was too much felt feel the guys
pain his dress his hope hope wrapped up
in something else
mmm-hmm probably took a booster just
before you'll be fine got everything set
up let's switch over to editing mode
I'll sever the link to the video lers
sensory array you'll be able to look
around freely seeing yours full cam
control in analysis mode so move around
zoom in and out whatever else you come
up with think of it as your own little
sandbox so analysis mode you control
playback can even pause when you feel
the need then you use the editor console
to unpause try it
plan simple do nothing odd don't get
creative you go in snatch the cash get
out and we sell the BD to those psycho
freaks from Studio gotta got it dream is
hell right well that's not all you can
speed things up or rewind whatever you
like give it a try rewind
roll it back to the top
now try fast-forwarding a bit
plan simple okay you can also reset the
recording that'll take you right back to
the beginning try it
now for some fun this here's why you
came in the first place
in analysis mode you get to view and
even scan details of the enviro recorded
by the BD roller focus on the heat the
gun this girl gets from his buddy at the
beginning now scanning
plans simple do nothing odd don't get
creative you go in snatch the cash okay
right here excellent let's move on now
heads up in analysis mode you can ferret
out background noise and conversations
if the roller got yourself this check
records everything every little detail
even the sights and sounds the roller
was never aware of to see the sources of
the recorded sensory signals switch to
the audio layer in the editor go ahead
and try that now okay good now you
should see several sound signatures in
the store choose one and holding on it
PACA sex case of broseph and a couple of
Zephyrs okay everybody so any thoughts
unbelievable seriously like what's
happening right next to me yeah it's how
BD recording implants work they pick up
everything all the elements in the
background then editor tweaks makes them
pop keep playing with the sound explore
it a bit we'll move on when you get
bored
what are you kissing the flooring money
yes sometimes you can analyze extra
layers in the raw stuff the roller is
fiber where picked up like what Ed's got
Karoshi optics that grab infrared
meaning you should be able to grab the
heat signatures from her recording huh
hello nice scanning works on peeps -
welcome to the wounded chick try
scanning her alright next thing scroll
forward to the part where our artist
gets a lead injection see that they shot
him and he never saw it coming
but you will here it comes
my favorite part of the game see the
blinking thing over the entrance
surveillance cam must have caught our
shooter you'll see in a sec cam feeds to
the screen behind the clerk roll back to
where the screams and the kids field of
vision then scan it
his own tune by Charlaine probably
planned to all along must've got a nice
slice of cred on the black market for a
beauty like this beady freaks are ready
to pay a premium for real flatline
anyway if you've seen enough you can
exit yeah too bad most of the biddies we
do here are only good for flog and
relock so brain balance is a pretty big
part of the cyberpunk universe it's not
just something used for adult films
there is an awful lot to it and there's
two sides
I'd really like you guys to help me
explore first is the law so how this
actually fits into the universe and then
there's the gameplay side so how players
will be interacting with it so Patrick
could you tell us more about the law of
brain dance
I would love to so in the world of
cyberpunk 2077 brain dance was invented
way back in the early 2000s at UC Santa
Cruz it was developed as a way of
recording a person's experiences and
then playing them back for someone else
as so that they could relive them as
though it was happening to them it was
originally used for things like therapy
and prisoner rehabilitation but by 2077
it's become this global media industry
including things like movies massive
mass entertainment things like that
video games some interactive things and
of course adult fare as well now in our
game we deal a lot with black brain
dances or ex biddies as we call them and
there are different types of those but
the one that you saw in the trailer just
there was a flat liner now that's where
the person recording it actually died
you
kind of a thrill but a mercenary can
also use them for various things and
you'll see that in the game of course
and from the gameplay perspective we
have been working a lot throughout last
year's trying to figure out the best way
how to use the brain dance in the game
as a mechanics so what we have settled
on is this Brandan's editor mode as a
player you will be able to run the
Brandan's in the edit mode and see
different clues that have been
registered on the peripheral of given
actor now as a player you can slide on a
timeline of the recording back and forth
trying to uncover different clues and
that clues are actually telling a story
in the game so as a player you will run
different investigations that will lead
you to different mysteries and you will
uncover them actually using that
brandon's as a mechanics in the game
so as Pavel was saying we use brain
dance as a storytelling tool it's not a
collectible it's not something where
you're gonna go in and you're gonna play
it you're gonna be like I've seen this
before
what we use brain dance for is to give
you a keyhole into the life of the
residents of night city and we can
explore things like childhood trauma
religion various philosophical ideas in
a way that you might not otherwise
experience in a story about a mercenary
on the tough streets so we've tried to
talk about some of the aspects that we
think the community will find really
exciting but you know while you're both
here I'd love to know what is it about
cyberpunk that you guys are really
excited for Patrick why don't you
thought so one of the things that I'm
most excited about in this game is the
characters and the way they interact
with the world we've got this really
interesting world that stretches all the
way back to the cyberpunk 2020 source
material and all of these events and all
those things but those don't mean
anything unless they connect with
characters and so when we come up with a
character we start with their function
what is this person what do they do in
this story but we don't stop there we go
back and we figure out what was their
childhood like what was their upbringing
like what kind of obstacles did they
face in this harsh reality and did they
overcome them and how did they overcome
them or did they not overcome them and
why
and you can see all of those things in
their environment in their dialogues in
sort of how they operate in the world
and we come up with up for all of our
characters now you look at someone like
Victor vector and you're gonna see
stories about his past in his
environment and in his dialogue you know
we come up with that stuff even if we
don't use it in the game because it
helps inform us as to who these
characters are and for me I would not be
myself if I would not say that I'm the
most excited about our quests like
without witcher 3 team with with patrick
and like everybody that has stayed with
us since the witcher 3 time we really
have grown so much we have learned so
much and we have used all that
experience to put them into the quests
that we have made and you will not find
really a filler in this game like
everything has a meaning like we put so
much effort into making sure that
everything is rewarding it's interesting
it's talking about characters as patrick
said it's talking about worlds it's
talking about emotions like touching the
player and they're really like a real
way and i just can't wait to find out
what you think
pavel I know you mentioned story and
quests and writing quest and when I was
last in the studio I had a look and I
saw a notebook on your desk and I would
love for you to show everybody this
notebook you ask for it so this is a my
notebook it's as a Southwest designer
the reason is because I dance salsa and
I'm a quest designer so I wrote the
start of this notebook actually when we
were really starting cyberpunk at the
very beginning I wrote them like a first
note and it says pretty much something
along the lines of it that we were
starting with a prototype and then you
know I kept on the basically noting
things that we've been working on for
like next years I remember once when our
concept artists actually approached me
and they said that they want to take a
look at my notebook I was like what for
actually and they took some pictures and
they told me yeah well you know because
we are looking for a reference material
for a notes of a psychopathic killer so
so yeah well you may find maybe
of my notes in the game Pavel and
Patrick thank you so much for joining me
I'm pretty lucky because I have read
some of the stories that you and the
team have written for brain dance and
I'm pretty excited for people to
discover them but before we do finish
today's episode there is just one more
thing we'd like to talk about earlier in
this episode I mentioned that media have
been getting hands-on with open